the laws of nature but the mathematical
thoughts of God and this is a quote by
Euclid of Alexandria who was a Greek
mathematician and philosopher who lived
about 300 years before Christ and the
reason why I include this quote is
because Euclid is considered to be the
father the father of geometry and it is
a neat quote regardless of your views of
God whether or not God exists or the
nature of God it says something very
fundamental about nature the laws of
nature are but the mathematical thoughts
of God that math underpins all of the
laws of nature and the word geometry
itself has Greek roots geo comes from
Greek for earth metree comes from Greek
for measurement you're probably used to
something like the metric system and
Euclid is considered to be the father of
geometry not because he was the first
person who studied geometry you could
imagine the very first humans might have
studied geometry they might have looked
at two twigs on the ground that looks
something like that
and they might have looked at another
pair of twigs that look like that and
said no this is a bigger opening what is
the relationship here or they might have
looked at a tree they might have looked
at a tree that had a branch that came
off that had a branch that came off it
like that and I said well there's
something similar about this opening
here and this opening here or they might
have asked themselves what is the ratio
or how does the what is the relationship
between the distance around a circle and
the distance across it and is that the
same for all circles and is there a way
for us to feel really good that that is
definitely true and then once you got to
the early Greeks they started to get
even more more thoughtful essentially
about geometric things when you talk
about you know the Greek mathematicians
like like Pythagoras but why who came
before Euclid but why the reason why
Euclid is considered to be the father of
geometry and why we often talk about
Euclidean geometry is around 300 BC and
this right over here is a picture of
Euclid painted by Raphael and no one
really knows what you could look like
even when he was born or when he died so
this is just Rafael's impression of when
you what Euclid might have looked like
while he was teaching in Alexandria but
what made you chlid the father of
geometry is really his his writing of
Euclid's elements and what the elements
were were 13 volumes of essentially a 13
volume textbook and arguably the most
famous text book of all time
and what he did in those 13 volumes is
he essentially did a rigorous thoughtful
logical march through geometry and
number theory and then also solid
geometry so geometry in three dimensions
and this right over here is the
frontispiece for the english version of
or the first translation of the English
version of Euclid's elements and this
was done in 1570 but it was obviously
first written in Greek and then during
much of the Middle Ages that knowledge
was shepherded by the Arabs and it was
translated into Arabic and then
eventually in the late Middle Ages
translated it back translated into Latin
and then obviously eventually English
and when I say that he did a rigorous
March what Euclid did is he didn't just
say oh I think the you know the what if
you take the square of one side of a
right triangle this is the length of one
side of a right triangle and the length
of the other side of the right triangle
is going to be the same as the square of
the hypotenuse all these other things
and we'll go into depth about what all
of these things are means he says I
don't want to just feel good that it's
probably true I want to prove to myself
that it is true and so what he did in
elements especially the six books that
are concerned with planar geometry in
fact he did all of them but from a
geometrical point of view he started
with basic assumptions so he started
with basic assumptions and those basic
assumptions and geometric speak are
called axioms or postulates and from
them he proved he deduced he deduced
other statements or propositions or
these are sometimes called theorems and
then he says now I know if this is true
and this is true this must be true and
he could also prove that other things
cannot be true so then he could prove
that this is not going to be the true he
did he didn't just say well every circle
I've said has this property says I've
now proven that this is true and then
from there we can go and deduce other
other propositions or theorems and we
could use some of our original axioms to
do that and what's special about that is
no one had really done that before
rigorously proven beyond a shadow of a
doubt across a whole broad sweep of
knowledge so not just one proof here or
there
for an entire for an entire set of
knowledge that we're talking about a
rigorous march through a subject so that
he could build this scaffold of axioms
and postulates and theorems and
propositions and theorems of
propositions are essentially the same
thing and essentially for about two
thousand years after Euclid so this is
unbelievable shelf life for a textbook
people didn't view you as educated if
you had not read if you did not read and
understand Euclid's elements and
Euclid's elements the book itself was
the second most printed book in the
Western world after the Bible this is a
math textbook it was second only to the
Bible when the first printing presses
came out they said okay let's print the
Bible what do we print next let's print
Euclid's elements and to show that this
is relevant fair in into the fairly
recent past although some would you know
whether not you argue that about 150
hundred 60 years ago as the recent past
this right here is a direct quote from
Abraham Lincoln obviously one of the
great American presidents I like this
picture of Abraham Lincoln this is
actually a photograph of Lincoln in his
late 30s but he was a huge fan of
Euclid's elements he would actually use
it to find to in his mind he would while
he was riding his horse he would read
Euclid's element while he was in the
White House you would read Euclid's
element but this is a direct quote from
Lincoln in the course of my law reading
I constantly came upon the word
demonstrate I thought at first that I
understood its meaning but soon became
satisfied that I did not I said to
myself what do I do when I demonstrate
more than when I reason or prove how
does demonstration differ from any other
proof so in Lincoln saying there's this
word demonstration that kind of means
something more more you know proving
beyond doubt something more rigorous
more than just simple you know kind of
feeling good about something or
reasoning through it I consulted
Webster's dictionary so Webster's
dictionary was around even around when
Lincoln was around they told of certain
proof proof beyond the possibility of
doubt but I could form no idea of what
sort of proof that was I thought a great
many things were proved beyond the
possibility of doubt without recourse to
any such extraordinary process of
reasoning as I understood demonstration
to be I consulted all the dictionaries
and books of reference I could find
but with no better results you might as
well have defined blue to a bot to a
blind man
at last I said Lincoln he's talking to
himself at last I said Lincoln you can
never you never can make a lawyer if you
do not understand what demonstrate means
and I left my situation in Springfield
went home to my father's house and
stayed there till I could give any
proposition in the six books of Euclid
at sight so the six books concerned with
planar geometry I then found out what
demonstrate means and went back to my
law study so one of the greatest
American presidents of all time felt
that in order to be a great lawyer he
had to understand to give any be able to
prove any proposition in the sixth book
of in the six books of Euclid's elements
at sight and and also once he was in the
lighthouse you continue to do this to
make him in his mind to fine-tune his
mind to become a great president and so
what we're going to be doing in the
geometry playlist is essentially that
what we're going to study is we're going
to think about how do we really tightly
rigorously prove things we're
essentially going to be in a slightly
more modern form be studying what Euclid
studied 2,300 years ago to really
tightening our reasons to really tighten
our reason to really tighten our
reasoning of of different statements and
being able to make sure that when we say
something we can really prove what we're
saying this is really some of the most
fundamental real mathematics that you
will do arithmetic was really just
computation now in geometry and what
we're going to be doing is really
Euclidean geometry this is really about
what this is really what math is about
making some assumptions and then
deducing other things from those
assumptions